tout le monde connaît la laitue iceberg
ça fort beau mais cette couleur vert
pâle
bâtir en
96 % du contenu c'est de l'eau non c'est
une grosse goutte d'eau si on veut
pendant plus de 40 ans et la laitue
qu'on retrouve sur nos tables à longueur
d'année on cherche aujourd'hui à redorer
son blason à lui redonner ses lettres de
noblesse la texture
trois questions
[Musique]
cette variété de laitues pommées a vu le
jour en 1894 développé par washington
est libre pis un américain originaire du
nouveau brunswick au début des années
1900 le trait révolutionne le transport
des marchandises
c'est vraiment partir des années 30 tout
ce qu'elle a commencé à envoyer un
bateau aux états unis sur la côte est de
la californie qui est l'endroit où la
police est le plus à l'époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand on espère qu'ils auront transporté
sur déchargement de place et donc plus
qu'elle restait bien une fois
contrairement aux autres pommes de
salades de l'est dessus ce qui rend les
bergs accessible est devenue une lame à
double tranchant
le perfectionnement du transport
réfrigéré permet la distribution
d'autres variétés plus fragiles comme la
beauce ton la crise et la romaine les
mélanges printanier sa popularité font
petit à petit ce qu'on sait les fleurs
qui ont fait la guerre
des variétés là dessus qu'ils ont été
adoptés par les communautés culturelles
qui sont émigrés aux pays plus vers la
fin
justement des années 80 début 90 ça
c'est la pointe de l'iceberg
mais la face cachée de notre mal aimés
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on la retrouve
partout en europe comme un produit de
luxe un produits de spécialité c'est le
début de la plantation au total vous
allez en semences et combien de plans
pour la saison oui d'ailleurs 5 millions
moi c'est là qu'ils n'ont 35%
mais dans le sac de laitue américaine
que je vais acheter des jeux coupé près
mélanger est-ce que ça se fait que je
retrouve l'iceberg québécoise oui oui
c'est sûr les usines la côte est
américaine mais moi en attendant d'artv
l'étude du québec parce que tu allais tc
des camions à tout les jours glace à la
truffe le site qui poussent là là ça va
se retrouver
ça l'ami magot sandwich ou
l'iceberg est de loin la laitue les plus
économiques elle coûte 2 2 6 fois moins
cher le kilo que les autres variétés
côté fibre sa valeur équivaut aux autres
les tuent environ 4 grammes de fibres ce
qui n'est pas à dédaigner mais pour le
reste on est loin du concentré
d'antioxydants et de nutriments à la
mode on a un légume tu es très peu
concentré en nutriments on le voit la
couleur inverse pâlotte un peu ses
signets du contenu en vitamine c'est
assez faible une pomme de scheiber comme
celle d'haïti vaud est si je compare
avec l'ère romaine
2 feuilles de romaine pour le contenu on
termine à
pour notre plaisir est le sien le chef
louis françois marcotte la revisite même
dans son livre de recettes est ce
qu'avec des avantages joaillier
complètement insignifiant attaché régime
il opte parce qu'il ya quand même des
avantages enfin c'est la conservation
travaux pas tomber un camping ça se
conserve dans un sac à dos au delà du
mythe certes elle a besoin d'offrir ce
ballon das est beaucoup plus fragile
verser pour ce groupe ça c'est la
conserver
ce que je trouve intéressant de
l'iceberg cela vaut le quartier parce
qu'une espèce de nul qui vaut ce n'est
toutes les failles en ce sens ça c'est
parce que c'est beaucoup c'est le voilà
qu'ally qt avec le car si je vois couper
en quartiers
reste à savoir si je suis déçu parce que
le défi a été lancé un peu plus loin
l'iceberg en soupe froide
juste hijab bouillon de légumes ça pour
est un bouillon de poulet
je vais laisser chauffer sa 1,5 million
non le surf oise et de cu là où d'autres
qui diagramme étaient là aux congés la
page donc je sais la recette la main
facile dessous sa femme soupe d'aidé
my phone et finalement gb mt servi dans
son restaurant burger sambi ken read
c'est ça la porchetta donc ceci tu flanc
pas et le reste c'est la partie
intéressante et jusqu'où peut écouter un
petit gâteau d'icebergs c'est ce que ces
propos mais trop tard de friser le
propos m salade non s'il a exposé qu'il
a prêché en france et en débarrassera
jamais notre expert j'aime ça regarde ça
m'a longtemps
classée
[Musique]
merci françois et charles peut-être
qu'on va avoir envie de cuisiner avec
l'iceberg je souhaite